los riesgos son uno de cada tres en el
próximos cincuenta años
al mega terremoto en la costa oeste y por lo tanto
una certeza estadística que para el
la junta de conferencia de canadá plantea
mucha incertidumbre sobre el
capacidad de pago de las aseguradoras
proyecto de ley de casi 130 mil millones
dólares por uno grande de 9 en
escala de Richter
poner las cosas en perspectiva
presupuesto anual para todo Quebec
un bus de todo canada es 230
miles de millones de dólares las aseguradoras no
no podrá pagar esta factura y
directamente ya sea a través de sus impuestos
o por un aumento en su prima
seguro para todos los canadienses mayores de edad
para asegurar un alojamiento o un vehículo
sin duda verán sus primas aumentar
en la investigación que ya ha sido
hechos de la cama costo potencial de un
grandes terremotos no muy lejos de pedro
antunes s y director analítico
pronósticos económicos o confianza
board of canada en el escenario que tenemos
de elegir encontraríamos de hecho poco a poco
casi 40 2 millones de todas estas pérdidas
el beso es asegurable en el sentido de 42
mil millones supera la capitalización
toda la industria por lo que queríamos
estresado para hacerlo un guión
estrés para la industria porque sabemos
que el sistema presenta lo principal
llega sexy una runa aseguradoras que
comienza a tener dificultad si un
aseguradora que iba a quebrar
de hecho, las otras aseguradoras en Canadá
debe tener en cuenta que tuvimos que
hecha
ser responsable de las quejas
el sistema actualmente es muy bueno para
proteger a los consumidores
es un sistema todo funciona bien
casi todos los casos, pero si alguna vez
un sistema donde uno a un estrés que viene
que pasan su grado de
mayúsculas bien nos encontramos en
una situación en la que no sólo tenemos
impactos económicos muy muy raros
causados ​​por la destrucción sino también nosotros
tendría impactos económicos causados
por el contagio financiero que sería
en realidad no se retira en todo el país
necesitamos un sistema que pueda
apoyando las naves tridente en dos
en tal escenario
si mantenemos la guía de mayúsculas
actualmente en la industria estamos hablando
de 30 a 35 mil millones podría realmente
cubrir este tipo de terremoto más
niñas
el escenario coincide con un terremoto que
realmente se hizo más raro cuando 1.5 ren
eso es lo que tal vez pasaría
nunca pero pero también es posible
deja que suceda en 2014 la oficina
compañía de seguros de Canadá reveló la
impactos de diferentes escenarios sísmicos
primero evaluamos los efectos de un
terremoto con una magnitud de 9 0
fuera de la columbia británica
como sucedió fuera de Japón
simular pérdidas económicas
entonces ascendería a casi 75 mil millones
de dolares
un segundo escenario solo es feliz con un
Terremoto de magnitud 7.1 cerca
la ciudad de quebec que también es
sujeto a grandes terremotos
en este caso las pérdidas económicas en
el corredor de ottawa montreal quebec
estaría cerca de los 61 mil millones de dólares
un temblor así que cuando miras un
proyecto en solitario del nombre de mujer que conocemos
para que podamos prepararnos
parlamentario te ruega soldado
jubilado canadiense richard bouchard
trabajó activamente en el expediente de
elaboración del post del plan de emergencia
terremoto de coa británico
durante los años 2005 a 2008
generalmente debido a
montañas rocosas y la ayuda que
me gustaría traer sus próximos plazos
ella pondrá el área de ottawa ella
vendrá no me conozco de manitoba
pero el hacha, siempre hablamos, mandó mensajes
aviones para añadir a las preocupaciones de
pronosticadores y estadísticos esto
signos de otoño tal vez antes
corredor de un mega terremoto en preparación
bajo la costa oeste de canadá han sido
decidido en forma de una columna de
humo
columnas de gas de hecho que
escaparon de un volcán que estaban
visto en la cima del mont migaud todo
cerca del pueblo de 2000 habitantes de
pan toro sosteniendo como l'o annick qui
está a sólo 150 km al norte de
vancouver una ciudad de un millón y medio
habitantes
el tercero mas grande del pais
que fue visto en un primer momento por un piloto
helicóptero
volaba sobre la región y vio
abriendo prenda en el glaciar esta palabra
le grita a sus aberturas ahí pudimos ver
gas saliendo directamente jones y
vulcanólogos y profesor de
universidad simon fraser en la costa
el oeste de Canadá también
asesor del ministerio canadiense
recursos naturales por lo que es
puede ser un indicio de algo
lo que cambia es normal o
es algo diferente
entonces eso es lo que estamos buscando
el momento no debe preocupar
[Música]
sarpullido o algo
pero este tipo de cosas que precisamente
entonces tenemos que estar atentos
acaban de instalar
menos un sismómetro y hay
planea instalar un segundo para
el momento y precisamente esa es la idea es
también tenemos el grado de red para el
terremotos por lo que con este y el
temporadas si alguna vez hubo suficiente
nuevo magma la roca fundida que
rosa profundo deberíamos
espera ver signos de esto
movimiento de un pequeño terremoto
que se puede detectar con una red
bajo el volcán un reportaje de radio
canadiense internacional